Proc, moin!
Kann man vom zweiten Bildschirm kurz was nachgucken.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass Twitch heute so schnell checkt, dass der Stream on ist.
Ich bin ziemlich im Arsch heute, ich habe gedacht, ich mache trotzdem noch mal Stream an.
Ich muss euch mal was fragen.
Geht euch das auch manchmal so, dass ihr manche Leute einfach nicht versteht, was die sagen?
Ich meine nicht akustisch, weil auch geschrieben im Moin Michael 5 Spieljahr, und wie ist es mit Lisa gelaufen?
Sowohl geschrieben als auch gesprochen, ihr versteht sie einfach nicht.
Ich habe mit einem Kollegen auf der Arbeit und ich verstehe ihn einfach nicht.
Ich denke mir jetzt mal was aus, ich frage ihn nach dem Motto, kannst du dich per SSH einloggen und neu starten?
Und dann kommt als Antwort von ihm, ok danke.
Was will er mir sagen, der antwortet immer so, ich verstehe ihn einfach nicht.
Der antwortet immer so, dass ich es nicht verstehe.
Nein das ist kein Autoresponder, der schreibt das wirklich.
Es kann auch sein, dass er mich nicht versteht, es kann auch sein, man soll er halt was sagen, Max was meinst du?
Keine Ahnung, der müsste es eigentlich, ich verstehe ihn nicht.
Oder ein anderes Beispiel, dabei hat er wirklich Plan von dem was er macht, ich verstehe ihn einfach nicht.
Auch was, ich habe ihn gefragt, kannst du die zwei Merchrequests aus dem Bitbucket jetzt in GitHub aufmachen?
Hab ich ihn gefragt, ist doch eigentlich relativ klar oder? Und dann meint er, ich pushe erst heute Abend was, war die Antwort da drauf.
Da muss nichts gepusht werden, ist alles da? Ich verstehe es nicht, ich habe wirklich Probleme ihn zu verstehen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das meint er schon ernst, ich verstehe ihn bloß nicht.
Richtig Ayaya, aber Massive Ayaya.
Ach der Cutebot hat es jetzt gecheckt, das ist nice.
Rüpel, Dankeschön für den Sub, Mr. Moogame, 203 IQ, aber Massive IQ.
Nein, nein, der hat auch nicht so viel zu tun, ich kann das ausschließen, ich glaube der will das eins zu eins so schreiben, nur verstehe ich die Antwort nicht.
Ich habe mit keinem Problem ihn zu verstehen, aber ihn verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Vielleicht sagt der X und meint eigentlich Y, das kann natürlich sein, das wäre möglich, aber ich verstehe ihn trotzdem nicht.
Die Benachrichtigung ist nicht jebait, die ist real.
Wenn ich jetzt Battlefield 2042 spiele, da kriege ich gar nichts auf die Reihe und wahrscheinlich reg ich mich nur auf.
Na gut, ich meine ich reg mich wahrscheinlich sonst auch auf, aber noch mehr.
Ja dann, dann ist ja gut, da konntest du ja punkten.
Ja das gibt es auch, wir haben da auch so einen Spezialist, das ist ganz schlimm.
Wenn bei uns Wartungsarbeiten, ne wie heißt das offiziell?
Chat hilft mir auf die Reihe, ITIL, ITIL Style, ich sage immer Wartungsarbeiten Runde, wie heißt das nochmal?
Change Advisory Board, genau jetzt habe ich es wieder, das ist so ITIL Begriff und alle die ITIL Begriffe verwenden sind.
Fivehead irgendwie, kommen sich zumindest so vor. Change Advisory Board, da haben wir auch jemand.
Der stellt immer Nachfragen, um aus Prinzip nachzufragen und genau so, genau so nach diesem Schema.
Man sagt zum Beispiel, ja dann müssen wir das Zertifikat austauschen, aber das haben wir schon so oft gemacht.
Da macht man einen Server, danach den zweiten und da kriegt keiner was mit.
Gerade irgendwie um 1 Uhr nachts passiert da nichts, es sei denn es kommt wirklich gerade irgendwie zu dieser millisekundenen Request.
Ich würde sagen es ist Standard Change und dann kommt dann irgend so ein Typ dann an und meint,
also das ist immer der gleiche, kommt dann an und meint, da hätte ich noch eine Frage dazu.
Gibt es denn da auch ein Rollback Szenario, weil ich habe ja gerade gehört ihr tauscht die Zertifikate aus.
Was willst du denn da rollbacken, das Zertifikat läuft aus, entweder du tauscht es nicht aus, dann läuft es ab oder du tauscht es aus.
Was willst du denn da rollbacken? Was willst du denn da rollbacken?
Und dann fragt er, ja aber du sagtest doch die Zertifikate werden ausgetauscht.
Also beim Austausch der Zertifikate sollte auf ein ordnungsgemäßes Rollback Szenario geachtet werden.
Das ist so einer der wiederholt auch die Sachen immer wieder uns komplett am Thema vorbei eigentlich.
Genau was willst du rollbacken bei Zertifikaten, gerade bei Zertifikaten die dringend getauscht werden müssen, weil sie ablaufen.
Das war eh noch das geilste, ich weiß es ist Recycled Story, aber ich muss es einfach noch mal ganz kurz sagen.
Am geilsten war immer noch in irgendeiner, irgendeiner Rücksprache war ein Entwickler
und der hat einfach nicht verstanden, dass das Zertifikat ausgelaufen ist.
Ich habe ihm erzählt, also wir müssen das Zertifikat tauschen.
Das läuft hier ab, also es gibt gar keine Möglichkeit das nicht zu tauschen.
Oder man möchte quasi der gesamte Außendienst kann sich nicht mehr connecten.
Und dann meinte der Entwickler zu mir, also ich habe gerade nachgeguckt, das Zertifikat läuft noch bis 2035.
Und dann denke ich mir auch immer, ich habe verstanden wovon ich rede, ja nein.
Und er hat dann halt bei der CA nachgeguckt, ja die CA läuft bis 2035, wen juckt die CA?
Das sind dann immer so Leute, die sagen das so furchtbar selbstsicher und denken alle, die keine Ahnung haben, der hat voll den Plan.
Da erzählen die immer einen totalen Blödsinn.
Und am besten sind dann irgendwelche Manager Leute, das war ja auch geil.
Da ging es darum Zertifikat austauschen hin und da und Rollback und sonst wie.
Und ich habe dann halt am Ende gesagt, also nur mal so, dass das alle Beteiligten jetzt mitbekommen haben.
Wenn das Zertifikat bis in zwei Tagen nicht getauscht ist, dann kommt der gesamte Außendienst nicht mehr auf die Systeme drauf.
Also ich hoffe, ich möchte das jetzt nur nochmal betonen.
Und dann kam dann irgendein Manager Dude um die Ecke und meinte, ja was ist in zwei Tagen, wir haben doch jetzt Probleme.
Und ja macht was ihr wollt, macht so viel ihr wollt, egal, ich habe es gesagt.
Alter, das ist teilweise so Wahnsinn, man hat echt das Gefühl, in der IT sind 90% Leute,
die keine Ahnung haben von dem, wofür sie eigentlich da sind bzw. über was sie sich gerade unterhalten.
Unglaublich, kann ja nicht sein, weil sonst wird es wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktionieren.
Aber es muss schon ein echt hoher Anteil sein.
Doomsfab, danke schön für den Sub, also sehr merkwürdig alles.
Mit welchem Zeugnis-Shit hast du in deinem Berufsschulzeugnis abgeschnitten?
Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, 1,2 oder so, ich hatte fast nur einser, weil Berufsschule absolut Easy Mode war.
Ich habe nichts gemacht heute, ich habe sogar DS gespielt im Unterricht,
und einmal ist der Lehrer über das Ladegerät gefallen, hat eigentlich keinen interessiert.
Also Berufsschule ist wirklich easy as fuck gewesen.
Oder 1,3, also ich hatte, lass mal überlegen, ich hatte sogar in Sport eine 1, lol.
In Sport, Alter, ich muss unbedingt eher überlegen, wo hatte ich denn keine 1?
Es könnte sein, dass ich in der ganzen BWL-Geschichte,
ich glaube ich hatte in Englisch eine 2 und in BWL eine 2 oder so, und der Rest war ein 1.
Also wirklich Berufsschule war wirklich easy.
Kann sich das ja in seinem Abschluss-Pattel, wie auch immer das heißt,
dieses Abschluss-Ding, was du von der IHK bekommst, da kann man sich ja, wenn man das beantragt,
seinen Notendurchschnitt eintragen lassen, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Juckt keinen, wirklich, juckt niemand.
Mich hat nie jemals, also nicht nur ansatzweise mal nach Berufsschule,
du bist glaube ich der Erste, der mich nach Berufsschulnoten fragt jetzt seit 20 Jahren oder so.
Na gut, nicht so lange, so lange mache ich das, seit 15 Jahren.
Übrigens, was auch Fun-Fact, der gleiche Typ, der immer so komische Nachfragen stellt bei uns auf der Arbeit,
der hat auch manchmal so ganz komische Einwände, sowas nicht nur wie Rollback,
sondern wir wollten uns mal einloggen, nachts auf einer Kiste und dort,
ich glaube, irgendwelche Log-Dateien zippen oder so.
Also was total Banales, ja, war halt irgendwie die Festplatte voll,
ein paar Logs zippen und alles war wieder gut gewesen.
Und dann kam der Typ mit irgendeiner Gefahren- und Risikomatrix an
und dann wollte er ernsthaft, dass man anhand der Gefahren- und Risikomatrix das Zippen der Log-Dateien bewertet.
Und in der Risikomatrix stand dann so Dinger drin, wie Rollback-Verfahren vorhanden,
Zwei-Augen-Prinzip, bewährtes Verfahren, blablabla.
Und wir haben das mal wirklich just for fun, wir haben das just for fun mal bewertet nach diesen Fragen.
Und da kam raus am Ende, dass das Zipp von Log-Dateien also schon wirklich ein ganz kritischer Change ist.
Also manchmal erscheint mir das Verhältnis von Leuten,
die irgendwelche Organisationssachen machen und es nicht hinbekommen,
zu Leuten, die Technik machen, irgendwie unausgewogen.
So als hast du 80% irgendwelche Dummeschwerzer am Start und 20% die noch irgendwie ein bisschen Ahnung von Technik haben.
Und von den 20% ist ja der Schlimme und die meisten auch keine Ahnung.
Wenn ich mir angucke, Entwickler, die nicht wissen, dass ein Zertifikat,
also wie ein Zertifikat und wann ein Zertifikat abläuft.
Letztens sind Change, da wollte einer, dass wir neue Unit-Files auf manche Linux-Server packen.
Und die Unit-Files sollten dann, also das Unit-Files ist quasi sowas wie der Autostart unter Windows.
Also simpel, naja, nicht wirklich, aber ich glaube die meisten Leute können sich das am besten vorstellen.
Das ist quasi sowas wie Service-Auto-Start unter Windows.
Da legt man ein Text-File hin, wo im Prinzip drin steht, was gestartet werden soll.
Und in diesem Start-File musste man halt dann den eigentlichen Service starten.
Und man hat dann ein weiteres Start-Script aufgerufen von ihm und ein weiteres Stoppscript aufgerufen von ihm.
Und das erste was passiert ist, ich leg ein Unit-File hin, starte die Unit, failed, geht nicht.
Ich stoppe die Unit, Endlosschleife, im Stoppscript.
Der hat irgendwie hardcoded da ein Pit-File drin, was nicht existiert hat und er nichts gefunden hat, keine Fehler abgefangen hat.
Und dann hing dann das Stopps, das muss man erstmal schaffen, ein Stoppscript, das in einer Endlosschleife hängen kann.
Ich frage mich allen Ernstes, wie die Leute da teilweise in ihre Jobs gekommen sind.
Ernsthaft?
Kein Timeout und nix.
Ich meine, die Unit geht glaube ich nach 45 Sekunden in failed oder so.
Aber trotzdem, Alter, das ist teilweise echt die planke Unfähigkeit, die einer jeden Tag entgegenspringt.
Aus allen Ecken.
Weder noch.
Ich habe noch nicht gewechselt, aber ich habe das Vorhaben auch noch nicht gestoppt.
Aber ich habe es nicht so eilig.
Also ich kam nicht vom Gymnasium und ich habe trotzdem die Berufsschule gemacht.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe mal in grauer Vorzeit was BWL-mäßiges gemacht.
Aber das möchte ich nicht weiter ausführen.
Ich habe festgestellt, das ist nichts für mich.
Aber das Berufsschulzeug ist doch eh nicht richtig wichtig, oder?
Ach so, das Berufsschulzeug, ich habe das Berufsschulzeug gelesen.
Das Berufsschulzeug, nein, das Berufsschulzeugnis ist nicht wichtig.
Das Berufsschulzeugnis interessiert wirklich kein Mensch.
Also gar kein.
Was bei einer Mitarbeiter funktioniert das Office-Tran vom Sechskonto nicht?
Welches bei ihr?
Ja, so Leute sind auch geil.
Ja, wie gesagt, Unfähigkeitenpersonen überall.
Ich werde auch manchmal zu irgendwelchen Besprechungen eingeladen.
Das sind dann die geilsten Dinge.
Ihr kriegt einfach random einen Anruf.
Kennt ihr das, wenn ihr random einen Anruf kriegt
von irgendeinem Besprechungsraum in Teams
und ihr seid nicht eingeladen und ihr fragt euch, was geht?
Was wollen die?
Dann geht ihr dran und das erste, was ihr hört, ist sowas.
Ja, es geht irgendwas nicht.
Habt ihr nicht gestern Abend Wartungsarbeiten gemacht?
Kann das daran liegen?
So nach dem Motto.
Und was sprecht ihr überhaupt?
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil ihr da viele Szenarien
aus der echten Welt verarbeitet habt.
Oh, du hattest die erste Berufsschulwoche an der Werder von Siemens Schule.
Ja, die Schule ist aber richtig kacke.
Es ist halt insofern ganz gut.
Du kannst halt AFK sein und trotzdem Einsatz schreiben.
Die Schule ist halt mega hässlich.
Dreckig, die Kantine kriegst du Dünnsches von.
Und zumindest war das früher so.
Wahrscheinlich ist das heute immer noch so.
Und es sieht generell aus wie im Knast.
Das ist dir wahrscheinlich auch aufgefallen, oder?
Dass es wie im Knast aussieht da drin und aufgeteilt ist.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Also wenn du drei Monate durchgehend für die Prüfung lernst,
ist die Berufsschule komplett unsinnig.
Nichtsdestotrotz, finde ich, ist Berufsschule nicht ganz unsinnig.
Aber zum größten Teil schon.
Aber manchmal macht man durchaus sinnvolle Sachen.
Und manchmal kann man tatsächlich noch was fragen,
was man nicht verstanden hat.
Und dann hat vielleicht auch mal einer Plan.
Ganz vereinzelt.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen bringt das nichts.
Dani Lull, 39 Monate.
Du bist ja wirklich schon von ganz Anfang an mit dabei.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Hyper Subscription.
Du bist Systemintegrator am zweiten Lehrjahr.
Was soll man dafür machen im neuen Lehrplan?
Cyberphysische Systeme.
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Das ist doch wieder so ein Wort,
was sich irgendwie ein superschlauer IHK-PyFat-Mensch ausgedacht hat, oder?
Was sind Cyberphysis?
Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ist ein Computer, der etwas in der physischen Welt steuert?
Ah!
Was für eine ultrabeknackte Bezeichnung.
Das ist ja absolut hängen geblieben.
Also im Prinzip der Microcontroller in meinem Klo,
der dafür sorgt, dass die Wasserdüse Wasser rausspritzt.
Das ist ein cyberphysisches System.
Aber das ist...
Okay.
Aber warum nennt man das nicht IoT?
Ganz ehrlich, cyberphysisches System ist so ein beknacktes Wort.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Passt das gut rein zum Systemintegrator?
IoT-Kram auf jeden Fall.
Da musst du dich ja auch ein bisschen mit Netzwerkgedöns beschäftigen.
Du musst dich vielleicht mit den ein oder anderen Microcontroller-Sachen beschäftigen.
Aber sag mal, was macht ihr denn da eigentlich dann so?
Was macht man denn in diesem Fach so?
Was kann man sich...
Ich meine, nur was ich mir darunter vorstelle, heißt ja nicht,
was die Berufsschule auch darunter vorstellt.
Die...
Hier.
Werner von Siemens Schule Frankfurt.
Das Ding sieht aus wie im Knast.
Ich habe es euch doch schon mal gezeigt.
Gibt es da überhaupt Bilder von innen?
Gibt es da Bilder von innen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Da trauen die sich nicht, Bilder von innen zu machen.
Gibt keine Bilder von innen.
Gibt nur Bilder von außen.
Die wissen auch genau, warum.
Ganz oben rechts, das ist aber nicht die Werner von Siemens Schule in Frankfurt.
Die Bewertungen sind immer noch zu geil, Alter.
Religion hatten wir auch irgendwie zwei Stunden
und dann war die krank für die nächsten fünf Jahre.
Fünf Jahre, drei Jahre.
Gab es da nicht...
Gab es nicht in Google Maps?
Wie kommt man denn jetzt zu den Fotos von Google Maps?
Google Rezensionen?
Wegbeschreibung vielleicht?
Von Hanau, na alles klar.
Gut, ähm...
Fotos.
Nee, nee, auf die Fotos kommst du woanders raus.
Ah, Sporthalle.
Ein Busch.
Der Knast von außen, der Knast von innen.
Penna-Matratzen.
Ein dunkler Weg.
Ein Klassenraum.
Man sieht leider das Ganze nicht von innen.
Was aber auch gut ist, weil von innen sieht das Ding wirklich aus wie im Knast.
Nee, hab ich noch nicht, hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Tja, da fragt man sich warum das so einfach geht.
Sind halt nur besonders fähige Leute da.
Hast du denn wieder Urlaub im Dezember?
Ja, ganz Dezember.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das mit der File Struktur hab ich schon gesehen.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Bestimmt fast so sicheres Passwort wie bei Uber.
Was weiß ich, keine Ahnung.
Irgendjemand hat mich gefragt, ob ich irgendwie ein Studio mal nachholen will oder so.
Nee.
Will ich nicht.
Also erstens hab ich mit 38 wenig Bock drauf nochmal zu studieren.
Und vor allem, wozu?
Warum sollte ich das machen?
Das würde ich nur machen, wenn ich sag, ja okay.
Mich würden da irgendwie die theoretischen Inhalte brennend interessieren.
So nach dem Motto, ich will mal ein bisschen Mathe lernen oder sowas.
Okay, ja.
Dann könnte ich mir das...
Ja, aber aktuell, also es gibt für mich eigentlich gesagt wenig...
Es ergibt für mich wenig Sinn, das zu machen.
Das wären 2 oder 3 Jahre, weiß gar nicht, 3 Jahre eher, weiß gar nicht, wie lange das geht.
In denen ich kein Kohle verdienen würde, in denen ich meinen Job nicht weitermachen könnte.
Und am Ende verdiene ich auch nicht mehr.
Also warum sollte ich das machen?
Alter, was ist mit den Leuten los?
Warum hat er irgendwelche Gewehre bei sich im Studentenwohnheim?
Lull, ist klar, ist klar.
Macht das mal nebenberuflich, alles klar.
Es gibt Leute, die machen...
Ich mein, guck mal, wenn du arbeiten gehst, dann machst du ja schon fast den ganzen Tag nichts anderes wie arbeiten gehen.
Aber wenn du arbeiten gehst und nebenberuflich studierst, dann machst du ja in der Zeit, wo du nicht arbeiten gehst, auch nichts anderes als zu lernen.
Nee, ja, aber ganz nachher, es ergibt für mich überhaupt keinen Sinn, warum ich das machen sollte.
Es ist ja noch nicht mal so, als hätte ich großartig bessere Gehaltsaussichten danach.
Das Einzige, wofür es gut wäre, ist, wenn ich mal zu einem Amt will, für irgendeine Laufbahn, wo sie sagen, du musst studiert haben.
Also es macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn für mich.
Wie ist aktuell Homeoffice-Regel bei dir in der Tage?
Drei Tage Homeoffice, zwei Tage Homeoffice, äh, zwei Tage, äh, drei Tage Homeoffice, zwei Tage Anwesen ist bei uns die Regel.
Dadurch, dass ich nur vier Tage die Woche arbeite, ist das immer ein bisschen fließend, ja?
Mal auch vielleicht einen Tag.
Ich kann dazu nichts sagen, ich hab nicht studiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Also, aus meiner Sicht beziehungsweise aus dem, wie es bei mir gelaufen ist, nee, wozu?
Ähm, das kann man aber so pauschal nicht sagen.
Ich mein, im Durchschnitt ist es ja tatsächlich so, dass Leute, die studiert haben, mehr verdient, also im Durchschnitt, ja?
Als Leute, die nicht studiert haben, auch in IT-Berufen.
Das muss jetzt eben nicht zwangsläufig auf euch zutreffen, also, natürlich habt ihr prinzipiell dann bessere Chancen.
Sonst kommt der Durchschnitt, kommt er nicht von ungefähr.
Aber wenn ihr Plan habt und in irgendeinem Bereich landet, wo man Leute sucht, was ja quasi mehr oder weniger jeder aktuell ist,
also, es sei denn, es interessiert einen halt, ja?
Du kannst da schon theoretisch, du hast dann theoretisch schon viele Sachen gelernt, die du jetzt als Fachinformatiker nicht wirklich lernst.
Also, beweis mal irgendwie die Laufzeit von einem Algorithmus oder sowas.
Das machst du halt als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration nicht.
Wenn du Mathe studiert hast, kannst du das schon eh.
Es ist halt die Frage, bringt dir das irgendwas in deinem Job, den du machst?
Und ist dein Arbeitgeber dafür bereit, mir auszugeben, dass du das kannst?
Ja, wenn es ein Job ist, wo man das braucht, bestimmt, vielleicht, weiß man nicht.
Aber ansonsten, wozu?
Würde ich nicht generell empfehlen.
Ausbildung ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Guck mal, es suchen aktuell, vor allem wozu, ja?
Wenn du, es sei denn, es sei denn, es interessiert halt dieser Aspekt besonders, ja?
Und du willst vielleicht auch wirklich spät in die Arbeit gehen.
Wo das Voraussetzung ist, meinetwegen, dann macht das alles Sinn.
Aber pauschal zu sagen, studieren gehen nach der Ausbildung, wozu?
Ich meine, Fachinformatiker werden eh händeringend überall gesucht.
Und du kannst dies ja aktuell, wenn du ein bisschen Ahnung hast,
nahezu aussuchen, wo du hingehst.
Also, insofern.
Warum?
Ich hab nicht studiert.
Ich hab nichts gewählt in der Uni.
Vier Tage, ja, ich mach seit 2000.
Ich sag mal so seit 2012, ungefähr.
Aber ich hab nicht studiert.
2012, ungefähr, arbeite ich Teilzeit nur noch vier Tage die Woche.
Ungefähr neun oder zehn Jahre mach ich das, ganz schön lang, oder?
Und es gibt zwei Punkte, die ich mir nicht erklären kann, so wirklich.
Wie ich es früher geschafft habe, fünf Tage die Woche.
30 Stunden, sonst glaube ich.
Könnten auch 32 Stunden sein.
Es sind 7,4 Stunden am Tag.
7,4 x 4.
30.
So, was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Genau, es gibt zwei Punkte, die ich mir nicht erklären kann, wie ich das geschafft hab.
Und zwar, wie habe ich es früher geschafft, fünf Tage die Woche,
sieben und halb, bzw. ich nenne es jetzt einfach, acht Stunden am Tag zu arbeiten,
in Frankfurt jeden Tag dorthin zu fahren,
mit dem Zug hin und zurück.
Wie habe ich das ausgehalten? Unbegreiflich, verstehe ich heute nicht mehr.
Und das nächste ist, wie habe ich es ausgehalten,
vier Stunden am Tag hinzufahren mit dem Zug,
jeden Tag hin und zurück.
Ich verstehe es überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das aushält.
Allein schon die Probleme, die man mit der Bahn hat, sind quasi schon Kündigungsgrund genug.
Und alles andere, man muss sich das mal vorstellen, ich habe das nie realisiert früher.
Ich bin um 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden, bin dann zum Südbahnhof gefahren, bin nach Frankfurt gelaufen.
Ich habe mir da überhaupt nichts bei gedacht, aber ich war morgens müde.
Ich war mittags, ich war auf der Arbeit, ich war morgens müde, mittags müde, abends müde.
Und als ich daheim war, war ich so müde, dass ich eigentlich schon fast vom Rechner eingepennt bin.
Ich habe eigentlich nichts gemacht, außer so vier Tage die Woche so ein bisschen vor mich hin vegetiert.
Und dann bin ich schlafen gegangen und das dann wieder.
Und dann hatte ich halt drei Tage, konnte ich halt Action machen.
Aber ich sage euch, das ist das Beste für alle Seiten, was passieren konnte,
für Leute, die Homeoffice machen können, ist Corona gewesen die letzten Jahre.
Weil es hat sich dadurch bei vielen Unternehmen etabliert, bei vielen auch bewährt
und viele Unternehmen hätten es gar nicht ausprobiert ohne Corona
und ohne die Pflicht dazu, dass sie es machen müssen, wahrscheinlich hätten es auch ein paar nicht gemacht.
Und dadurch, dass diese ganze Homeoffice-Thematik jetzt in vielen Bereichen Einzug gehalten hat,
ist es ja mittlerweile auch so, dass die Leute quasi ihre Jobwahlen zumindest zum Teil mit davon abhängig machen.
Das finde ich gut.
Weil ganz im Ernst, es haben wirklich alle nur, also in meinem Fall, ich kann ja immer nur von mir reden,
es haben alle Seiten nur Pluspunkte davon.
Ja, also mir, einfach ganz unabstrich, mir geht es besser und ich schaffe am Endeffekt sogar mehr.
Also es ist eigentlich für alle beteiligt nur besser.
Leider gibt es noch viele Unternehmen, die gar so viele Boomer-Managements sitzen haben,
die sie überhaupt nicht gebacken kriegen und meinen, wenn du den Leuten nicht 24-7 auf dem Monitor gucken kannst,
dann wird das nichts.
Aber vielleicht, und das ist ja glaube ich eines der Sachen, die bei Corona festgestellt wurden,
ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch ist, aber ich hatte in Corona-Zeiten den Eindruck,
dass die Leute, die eigentlich nichts können und nur schwätzen den ganzen Tag,
besonders stark gelitten haben unter Homeoffice.
Also die haben besonders stark gejammert über Homeoffice.
Also du konntest in der Regel sagen, wenn du von irgendeinem gehört hast,
oh Homeoffice und soziale Kontakte und oh Homeoffice.
Also du konntest zu 90% sicher sein, wenn einer über Homeoffice gejammert hat,
dann war das irgendeiner, der eigentlich nichts kann und nur schwätzt.
Alle anderen waren happy.
Die haben zwar nicht zwangsläufig das alles in Anspruch genommen,
manche haben gesagt, naja so ein Tag die Woche, zwei Tage die Woche und so will ich schon,
aber es gibt ja welche, die haben komplett immer rumgeheult den ganzen Tag über Homeoffice.
Und das sind in der Regel die, die eigentlich nur schwätzen und nichts machen,
bzw. wahrscheinlich nichts machen, die machen schon was, aber die können nichts, außer schwätzen.
Wahrscheinlich hatten die das Problem, dass sie quasi ihren gesamten Arbeitsinhalt
durch dummes Zeug schwätzen, definieren und das halt nicht ging.
Und dass man eben festgestellt hat, gerade dank Homeoffice,
dass man eigentlich ein Viertel der Leute gar nicht braucht,
weil ob die da sind oder nicht, macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Deswegen waren glaube ich auch so viele gegen Homeoffice.
Klar, du hattest auch Leute, die haben da wirklich Gründe, die ich nachvollziehen kann.
Also zum Beispiel einer bei uns auf der Arbeit meint, seine Familie, seine Frau, seine Kinder gehen ihm daheim zu sehr auf den Keks,
weil er will auf die Arbeit fahren.
Okay, kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen, wenn du da eine Ruhe haben willst?
Also wir hatten schon öfters mal irgendwelche Kollegen,
die sind lieber auf die Arbeit gefahren, weil sie Ruhe hatten vor der Familie.
Ganz schlimm war mal einer, da hat immer das Telefon geklingelt und er hat abgenommen
und du hast die Frau schreien gehört.
Das kann ich mir dran erinnern, hat es geklingelt bei ihm und du musstest eigentlich bloß zwei Sekunden warten
und du hast irgendwie gehört, Papa, du hast die Kinder im Hintergrund gehört,
dann hat die Frau im Hintergrund rumgeschrien und eins muss man ihm echt zugute halten,
der hatte wirklich bei diesen Sachen die Ruhe weg.
Also ihr müsst euch vorstellen, euch brüllen die Kinder im Telefon an, die Frau brüllt euch im Telefon an
und der Typ hat den Telefonhörer auf halb acht gehangen auf seinem Sitz und hat dann den Telefonhörer am Ohr gehabt
und wird ihm voll ins Ohr geschrien und dann so, aha, ja, wie sieht das aus mit der Hello Kitty Decke?
Jetzt gib mir doch mal bitte die Hello Kitty Decke wieder.
Aha, verstehe.
Da war so mega ruhig, ja.
War total entspannt, der hat sich wahrscheinlich gefreut, dass er jetzt auf der Arbeitssitzung nicht daheim ist.
Ich weiß das nur noch, die Kinder haben sich damals um die Hello Kitty Decke gekloppt und solche Dinge
und die haben dann, musst du dir mal vorstellen, ja, wie bescheuert das eigentlich ist.
Die rufen den Vater auf der Arbeit an, weil sie sich um die Hello Kitty Decke kloppt.
Aber der Typ, der ist geil, der ist super entspannt
und irgendwann hat er sich eine Kamera installiert, dass er dann daheim spyen konnte, was da gerade abgeht
und dann hat er dann von der Kamera zugeguckt, der ging eh ab
und dann hat er den Temperatursensor ins Wohnzimmer gesetzt, weil er gesagt hat, die vergessen immer die Tür zuzumachen
und dann hat er den ganzen Tag teilweise sich seinen Graf angeguckt von dem Temperatursensor daheim
und hat dann festgestellt, wenn es wieder ein halbes Grad runtergegangen ist, dass die wieder vergessen haben, die Tür aufzumachen
und das hat er dann denen, wenn die angerufen haben, immer erzählt, dass sie wieder vergessen haben, die Tür zuzumachen
Der hat Home Automation gemacht, bevor es Home Automation gab, Alter
Oh Mann
Der sparende Boss, ja
Okay, also, lass mal kurz lesen
Heute war auch wieder gut, haben in der Nacht heute sofort Firewall Updates entstehen
Oh, um sowas sind wir glücklicherweise ein bisschen rumgekommen
Dafür haben wir
Wie heißen diese Dinger?
Ich überleg gerade
Palo Alto? Gibt's sowas? Palo Alto Firewall?
Ja, sowas gibt's, Palo Alto Firewalls, haben wir
Hab ich zumindest öfters mal vernommen, diesen Namen
Mach ich aber nichts mit, ist nicht mein, ist nicht mein, ist nicht mein Gebiet
Okay, heute hatte der eine Kunde VPN-Probleme
Wir 30 Minuten Probleme suchen, festgestellt, dass der dann eben das Modem aktualisiert, einfach die Firewall und
Ja wie, ausgehend, Firewall, what? Was ist das denn?
Übrigens, wusste ihr, was ich gestern wieder machen musste?
Ich musste wieder mit dem rein englischsprachigen Telekom Techniker
Ihre komische Telekom Appliance aktualisieren
Ich bin ja immer ein bisschen shy am Anfang, wenn man Englisch only reden muss, aber das funktioniert tatsächlich, muss ich sagen
Mittlerweile brauchbar
Also ich kann mit dem zusammen Update machen und ein bisschen nebenbei schwätzen und es funktioniert alles
Nein, nicht die Polen, nicht die Polen, nicht die Polen, nein nein
Das war, wobei, vom Namen her könnte es vielleicht sogar einer gewesen sein
Ich würde ihn eher so in Tschechien oder so verorten, so vom Namen her
Aber die Telekom ist da wirklich sehr international aufgestellt
Also die haben dann einen aus Tschechien, dann haben sie irgendwie einen aus München, dann haben sie einen aus
Was, Singapur oder Japan irgendwie, der da dort remote arbeitet
Da muss man sagen, die sind da sehr international
Bist du Anwendungsentwickler? Nee
Gelernt habe ich Fachinformatiker System Integration 2007, ist schon ein bisschen her
Das kann sein, dass es das gewesen ist
Ja
Also aktuell ist das Beste, was man machen kann, mehr Gehalt verlangen
Weil die Leute werden wie verrückt gesucht
Haut da ruhig mal richtig, richtig rein und sagt denen, dass ihr mehr Geld haben wollt
Ich meine, das Leben wird nicht billiger
Das erste, was dann kommt immer ist so nach dem Motto, ah, Inflation und der Firma geht es ja gerade nicht gut
Das ist ein schlechter Zeitpunkt
Leute, ich glaube, ihr werdet nie hören, wenn ihr nach Gehaltserhöhung fragt, das ist ein guter Zeitpunkt
Die Standardantwort ist immer, ah, ganz schlechter Zeitpunkt
Aber Pech gehabt, für euch ist der Zeitpunkt auch vielleicht schlecht
Weil ihr jetzt auf einmal 200% mehr Heizrechnungen bezahlen müsst
Das ist immer, das ist immer, das ist immer gleiche, gleiche Geschwätze
Darf man sich nicht so sehr davon beirren lassen und muss regelmäßig denen auf den Keks gehen
Das kann auch sein
Aber ich hab ja eh schon vor ein paar Jahren aufgehört
Also spätestens seit ich nur Teilzeit arbeite, aufgehört, ähm, quasi
So zu denken, als ist die Arbeit quasi mein Hauptlebensinhalt
Weil ganz ehrlich, das beste, was man machen kann ist
Möglichst viel Zeit mit dem verbringen, worauf man Bock hat
Beziehungsweise, das ist vielleicht jetzt blöd ausgedrückt
Möglichst viel Zeit damit verbringen, was einem wichtig ist
Es muss ja nicht sein, worauf man Bock hat
Es kann ja auch zum Beispiel sein, dass man
Nicht Zeit mit Familie und sonst was verbringt
Da muss man vielleicht nicht sagen, so unbedingt so nach dem Wort
Boah, da hab ich jetzt richtig Bock drauf, Zeit mit der Familie zu verbringen
Aber das ist auch was, wo man sich später vielleicht dran zurückerinnert und sagt
Ah, war ja gut, dass ich mit dem Opa noch ein bisschen immer im Garten
Zeug gemacht hab oder so, auch wenn man keinen Bock drauf hat
Weil niemand, das kann man nicht oft genug sagen
Niemand, ja gut, außer vielleicht es war die eigene Firma
Aber ich sag's jetzt trotzdem mal, niemand wird sich denken
Bevor er den Löffel abgibt, so nach dem Motto, keine Ahnung
Ihr lauft gerade über den Zebra-Streifen, guckt nach links
Und der LKW kommt
Und das letzte, was ihr denkt ist, oh Scheiße, hätte ich mal mehr gearbeitet in meinem Leben
Ich glaub, das ist das letzte, was ihr denkt
Also ich glaub, die meisten werden sich denken, oh Scheiße
Manche werden sich denken, keck bei
Oder was auch immer, ja
Aber es wird sich keiner denken, oh hätte ich mal mehr gearbeitet
Nicht genug gehasselt, genau
Diesen Dienstag ging's, da war die Bahn halbwegs pünktlich
Die Ficker waren halbwegs pünktlich, genau
Das hat mich auch überrascht, ja
Ich kann euch zum Studium wirklich nichts empfehlen
Ich habe nicht studiert und ich hab keine Ahnung
Aber Doktor ist zumindest schon mal cool, weil jeder was mit dem Doktor anfangen kann
Aber Doktor ist wahrscheinlich auch mit Abstand das Schwierigste
Kann man Doktor in Informatik werden? Bestimmt, oder?
Ich glaube, ich hab noch nie einen Doktor in Informatik gesehen
Bei euch war die Mehrheit gegen Homeoffice
Das soll die Mehrheit halt kein Homeoffice machen
Haben sie halt Pech
Aber es sollen die Leute, die das machen wollen, das trotzdem ermöglichen
Wen juckts
Die Mehrheit entscheidet sich auch oftmals für dumme Sachen
Das heißt ja nicht, dass du das mitmachen musst
Ich hoffe nicht, dass sie dann sowas sagen wie
Ich meine, die Mehrheit guckt auch Big Brother oder Deutschland sucht den Superstar oder Let's Dance oder so ein Shit
Oder was gibt es da sonst noch in letzter Zeit, was richtig dumm ist und viele gucken
Dschungelcamp und so
Müll
Trotzdem ist es nicht gut, auch wenn die Mehrheit das guckt
Deswegen, ich hoffe, die ermöglichen es trotzdem
Was für eine Art Büro-Arbeitsplatz hast du eigentlich auf der Arbeit
Also, ok, das kann ich kurz erzählen
Also, ich hab den gleichen Stuhl wie daheim
Ein Sedus Mr.24, Bilder, zack, so ein Ding
Allerdings, hier daheim hab ich mit dieser Kopfstütze
Und auf der Arbeit ist es mit dieser Kopfstütze
Macht jetzt nicht so viel Unterschied
Also, den Stuhl, einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch
Ein Curved, frag mich nicht, 32 Zoll, 28 Zoll, was auch immer
4K-Monitor
Und ein Notebook, da dran
Das war's
Ach ja, und eine eigene Tastatur, eine eigene Maus, die ich mir mitgebracht hab
Ein Single-Monitor, ja, aber einen Wide-Screen-Curved, 4K-Ding
Damit komm ich auch klar
Das ist ja quasi wie zwei kleinere Monitore nebeneinander
Früher hatte ich zwei, mittlerweile hab ich noch einen
Auf der Arbeit hab ich eine Logitech, wie heißt das Ding?
Logitech G Otoys Core
Also, ich hab eine G502
Als Maus auf der Arbeit und eine Ducky One Skyline Tastatur
Mit Numblock, so ein Teil hier
Mit Numblock, der ist nicht da, nicht das, mit Numblock
Also, so eine Tastatur und die Maus auf der Arbeit
Die hab ich mir aber selbst mitgebracht
Aus dem einfachen Grund, weil ich wahrscheinlich durch jahrelanges Gaming
Einfach zu verwöhnt bin, was gescheite Input-Geräte angeht
Und ich mir diesen billigen Tastatur nicht klar gekommen bin
Das ist wirklich richtig billiger Müll
Also, ich mag beispielsweise auch keine Low-Profile-Tastaturen
So was, die kaum Tastenhub haben
Kann ich nicht haben
Das Einzige, was ich mit meiner Tastatur gemacht hab, ist
Also mit dieser Ducky One
Also, das Einzige, was ich gemacht hab mit der Tastatur
Ich hab mir Silikonringe gekauft für manche Tasten
Weil ihr kennt das aus dem Stream und ich weiß nicht, wie gut die...
Ich hab ja hier RTX Voice quasi für Hintergrundgeräusche noch
Und ich weiß nicht, wie sehr ihr das tippen
Und ihr irgendwelche Geräusche überhaupt hört
Aber ich hab den Hang dazu, manchmal auf gewisse Tasten zu hauen
Beispielsweise die Enter-Taste auf dem Numblock gehört dazu
Ich mach das gerne, ich schreib irgendwas im Terminal
Lese mir das nochmal kurz durch
Und dann klopp ich wie verrückt auf die Enter-Taste auf dem Numblock
Fragt mich nicht, warum es die Numblock-Enter-Taste ist
Und nicht die normale Enter-Taste, die ist viel größer
Aber ich hau irgendwie gern auf die Numblock-Enter-Taste
Und ich wollt den Leuten, die um mich drumherum sitzen, auf der Arbeit nicht zu sehr auf den Sack gehen
Deswegen hab ich da so einen kleinen Silikonring unter der Numblock-Taste, dass die grad so schlimm ist
Hey Max, kannst du etwas zu einem Job in einem Rechenzentrum sagen?
Klar, warum nicht?
Ich hab ja früher selbst zwar keinen Only-Rechenzentrums-Job gehabt
Aber als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet hab, früher
Ich war jeden Tag mehrere Stunden im Rechenzentrum
Also bitte eine Ahnung davon hab ich auch
Dauert bei mir zwar noch bis nächstes Jahr, bis ich mit der Schule fertig bin
Ich habe gesehen, in Frankfurt gibt es auch Rechenzentrums-Unternehmen, die ausbilden
Nein, in Frankfurt gibt es quasi, wo du hin spuckst, ein Rechenzentrum
Man sieht es der Sache nicht unbedingt an
Aber es gibt sehr viele
Würde ganz gerne was mit der Hardware machen
Da wäre ich da doch richtig
Aber es kommt drauf an, ganz ehrlich
So viel machst du im Rechenzentrum mit Hardware, was du dir vielleicht vorstellst, auch nicht
Also es ist nicht so, dass du da Rechner zusammen baust
Du wechselst dort vielleicht mal Festplatten oder sowas
Oder tauschst mal einen Netzteil aus
Aber das kann man sich nicht vorstellen wie bei einem Desktop-Rechner
Sondern du ziehst das raus, klappst es auf
Und tauschst den RAM-Riegel, machst es wieder zu oder ziehst hinten das Netzteil raus
Das hat mit Hardware nicht wirklich viel zu tun
Natürlich macht man was mit Hardware, aber das, was man sich darunter vorstellt, wahrscheinlich eher nicht
Du wirst relativ viele Kabel patchen
Also nicht selber krimpen oder sowas, das macht eigentlich kaum noch einer
Du wirst jede Menge Kabel patchen
Du wirst das Ganze überwachen
Und dich wahrscheinlich auch um Sachen kümmern, die auf den Servern laufen
Weil so reines Rechenzentrum ist langweilig
Was willst du da großartig machen?
Kannst du nicht den ganzen Tag Server einbauen
Oder Kabel patchen
Ah, ich bin nicht eingeloggt
Und hat Spaß gemacht
Ja, das war geil
Das war geil, wo der Typ seinen USB-Stick in den Fahrstuhl geschmissen hat
Und nicht nur, der hat nicht nur seinen USB-Stick in den Fahrstuhl geschmissen
Der ist in den Fahrstuhlschacht gefallen und unten in diese Ölwanne rein
Nein, nein, du sollst sie nicht bannen, Quatsch
Das ist alles blödes Gelaber
Das ist die Taktik
Also das ist alles Taktik
Das ist alles Taktik, dass du nicht mehr fragst
Man gibt sich ja mit sowas zufrieden und du hörst nie wieder was von
Das ist okay, das kann dein Chef wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht entscheiden
Aber dein Chef kann eine Empfehlung aussprechen
Die dann, je nachdem wie gut er das macht
Meistens auch abgelickt wird
Und dieses mit ich gebe das weiter und ich kann das nicht entscheiden
Er kann das nicht entscheiden
Aber da musst du das nach oben hin verkaufen, so wie du das ihm verkauft hast
Das ist sein Job, dafür ist er da
Das kann man ja nicht oft genug sagen
Man muss sich ein bisschen von diesem Gedanken davon verabschieden
So nach dem Motto
Wie sag ich das jetzt
Der Chef ist irgendwie so ein höheres Wesen
Der hat einen Job zu machen an dieser Position
Es gibt einen Grund, wozu die da sind
Das ist unter anderem Planung, Koordination, vielleicht Aufgabenverteilung
Es ist aber auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt
Das jeweilige Team nach außen hin gut darzustellen
Dafür ist der Teamleiter bzw. der Chef da
Und die Interessen des Teams auch vertreten zu seinen Chefs und weiter
Wenn er das nicht macht, ist er ein scheiß Chef, ganz einfach
Das muss man sich immer mal überlegen
Diese Position ist nicht dafür da, nur um zu nehmen
Diese Position muss auch was bieten
Zumindest wenn die wollen, dass man dahinter steht
Und der muss das ordentlich verkaufen
Dafür ist er da
Und gute Führungskräfte machen das auch
Es gibt leider viele schlechte Führungskräfte
Die das wahrscheinlich nur aus Prestig-Gründen anstreben, dass sie das auf den Lebenslauf schreiben können
Aber das klappt dann meistens nicht
Das läuft dann auch meistens nicht
Und man muss auch sehen, gerade so unteres Management ist eine wirklich kacke Aufgabe
Die ich im Leben nicht machen möchte
Wenn du Teamleiter bist oder Gruppenleiter und untere Management-Ebene
Du kriegst permanent von deinen Leuten vorgejammert, wie schlimm alles ist
Und du kriegst Anschiss von den Leuten über dir
Wie schlecht es doch läuft
Und du kriegst quasi Anschiss von beiden Seiten permanent
Also das ist wirklich eine Position, die möchte ich nicht machen
Sie müssten mir sehr viel Geld bezahlen, dass ich auch nur daran denken würde, das zu machen
Und mit sehr viel Geld meine ich wirklich so viel Geld, dass ich das 1-2 Jahre machen müsste und danach kündigen könnte
Für immer
Und so viel werde ich mir dafür nicht bezahlen
Ich würde das im Leben nicht machen
Das ist genauso wie ich nie im Leben Lehrer werden würde oder sowas freiwillig
Und das ist halt eine kacke Position
Das unterscheidet sich natürlich auch ein bisschen nach Firma und Kultur
Bei uns in der Bank ist das halt komplettes Boomer-Management von oben bis Mitte
Kannst du komplett knicken
Ein paar mittlerweile sind jetzt schon ein bisschen jünger
Und machen auch durchaus Sachen, wo ich sagen würde, da hat sich ja mal einer Gedanken gemacht
Aber das meiste kannst du da nicht nachvollziehen
Ja, da muss ich sagen, also meine Chefs, die ich bisher hatte
Sagen wir mal, mein letzter Chef, der hat sich da Mühe gegeben, der konnte an vielen Stellen glaube ich auch nicht so viel bewirken, wie er wollte
Aber er hat es wenigstens probiert
Hat ja auch mit mehr Geld ein paar Mal geklappt
Mein aktueller Chef, den schätze ich auch in dieser Richtung ein, wobei den habe ich noch nicht so lange
Den davor konntest du komplett knicken
Den davor konntest du auch komplett knicken
Und den beim Provider konntest du auch komplett knicken
Also ich hatte jetzt keine Ahnung, die Jahre über 7-8 verschiedene Chefs und 2 davon haben was getaugt
Gar nicht so einfach da was zu finden
Das ZDF hat Quiet Quitting total falsch verstanden
Haben sie?
Da geht es ja im Prinzip darum, dass man sich nicht kaputt schafft
Was eines der besten Trends der letzten Jahre ist, dass die Leute mal erkannt haben, dass der Arbeitsvertrag nicht nur für die andere Seite quasi gilt
Sondern für die andere Seite auch
Und wenn da drinnen steht, du machst das und das oder bist da und dafür eingestellt, dann kommen die mit was anderem und wollen, dass du nachts was machst, da steht nix von Nachtarbeit drin
Dann machst du keine Nachtarbeit
Man kann das übrigens alles machen
Ich würde abraten davon zu sagen prinzipiell direkt von Anfang an, ach hört mir auf mit dem Scheiß, mach ich nicht
Das muss ein bisschen beidseitig sein, also sagen wir mal so
Wenn ihr gefragt werdet so nach dem Motto hier wir müssen Wartungsarbeiten machen und wir hätten gerne ein Techniker dabei, kann das 23 Uhr einer von euch machen
Da würde ich prinzipiell auch schon ab und zu mal sagen, ja klar, warum nicht
Wenn dann im Gegenzug aber, wenn ich das nächste Mal sag, Mist Leute, ich hab vergessen, dass, was weiß ich, meine Oma Geburtstag hat
Und ich muss hier mal ein bisschen früher weg oder an dem Tag kann ich nicht oder was auch immer, ist egal was
Oder ach ich hab zwar Urlaub beantragt erst ab 2. aber ich will schon im ersten losfliegen
Und wenn man dann da auch sagt, ist ok, machen wir, tragen wir ein, passt schon, dann ist das ok
Wenn es natürlich immer nur andersrum läuft so nach dem Motto, wir wollen was von euch und man suggeriert den Leuten dann auch immer unterschwellig
So nach dem Motto, da kannst du doch nicht nein sagen, boah das ging mir bei meinem vorvorletzten Chef mega auf den Sack
Das ist so einer und das probiert er heute immer noch
Der hat ja immer erzählt so nach dem Motto, da kann man doch jetzt nicht absagen oder kann man doch nicht nein sagen, doch kann man, warum nicht
Wenn das nicht im Gleichgewicht ist, dass das was man quasi mehr macht über das hinaus quasi nicht ja entsprechend gewürdigt wird
Mit dass einem beispielsweise mal in anderen Situationen entgegengekommen wird
Wie auch immer geartet ja, man muss halt selbst das Gefühl auch haben, ja ok, das ist ausgeglichen
Ich mach mal hier was mehr, aber dafür wird an anderer Stelle auch mal ein Auge zugedrückt, dann ist das vollkommen ok
Ansonsten klar kann man das sagen
Wir hatten auch mal einen Doktor in der IT bei uns
Allerdings war da kein Doktor in IT, sondern Archäologe
Kein Witz, ich weiß bis heute nicht wie der Typ dahin gekommen ist
Das wusste er erstmal schaffen von Archäologie zu irgendwelchen IT Geschichten
Das war aber wirklich nicht das Richtige für ihn, der ist da halb verzweifelt
Klar, wer macht das heute nicht
So ein richtiges Grindr Game fehlt mir allerdings zur Zeit
Ich finde Meetings über Teams auch viel angenehmer als in echt
Gerade mit Screen Sharing, so nach dem Motto ach warte mal ich zeige euch nochmal schnell was
Bald, bald, aber nicht im Arbeitsrechner, in meinem neuen Rechner
Chat was sagt ihr, NumBlock ja oder ne
Ich persönlich will keine Tastatur ohne NumBlock
NumBlock muss, 60% beste
Also ich würde jetzt sagen die meisten stehen auf NumBlock, aber ein paar nicht
Zum Spielen braucht man das nicht, aber nachdem ich die gleiche Tastatur zum Spielen wie zum Arbeiten verwende hier
NumBlock
Hast du deine Vice Campan draußen hängen oder ist die diese in der Wohnung
Ich hatte eine draußen und ich habe mir so ein Silikon Gehäuse damals gekauft dafür
Aber die ist immer wieder kaputt gegangen, mittlerweile ist die so kaputt, dass der Micro SD Karten Slot gar nicht mehr funktioniert
Die ist für außen nicht zu gebrauchen
So muss das sein, so muss das sein
Hups jetzt bin ich gerade mit den Stuhlen übers Kabel gefahren, fuck
Warum, warum erschreibt man irgendwas in C++ für seine Abschlussarbeit, will man sich da irgendwie quälen oder was ist da dahinter Kunde
Chizipo, Massive Subscriptions Dankeschön
NumBlock
Ist schon ein bisschen was dran ja
Na gut, also es gibt einen Punkt wo ich finde wo man universell
Naja, wo man aber schon ganz gut abschätzen kann ob man eine gescheite Führungskraft hat oder nicht
Ich meine das ist nicht ein Bewerbungsgespräch wenn man schon da ist
Und zwar sind die daran interessiert das was man macht gut zu verkaufen
Also sprich geht es nicht nur darum ist das rechtzeitig fertig und wenn nicht dann wird sich beschwert oder was ist hier los oder kannst du nicht noch zusätzlich machen oder sonst was
Sondern wirklich was man macht dass man merkt dass quasi das Interesse besteht dass die Arbeit die das eigene Team macht
Dass man versucht das gut zu verkaufen und wenn das passiert ist schon mal ein ziemlich großer Hinweis für dass die Führungskraft sich zumindest Mühe gibt und sie wahrscheinlich was taugt
Natürlich gibt es noch viele andere Punkte aber wenn das probiert wird und nicht nur so nach dem Motto das alles quasi verkaufen dass man jetzt selbst das verantwortet hat
So nach dem Motto haha ohne mich wäre dieses Team kacke und nur wegen mir läuft es so gut und alles ist nur geil
Das mag der vielleicht für seine eigene nächste Gehaltsforderung gut sein wobei ihm das sein Chef wahrscheinlich auch nicht abkauft
Aber wenn du einen Chef hast der beispielsweise wenn du dem erzählt hast gibt es ja meistens monatliche wöchentliche was auch immer
Gibt es mal irgendwelche Termine wo man sich dann drüber ein bisschen auskotzen kann was gut läuft was nicht gut läuft
Und wenn er dann Interesse dran hat so nach dem Motto kannst du mir die und die Punkte noch mal erklären dann erzähle ich da was zu in der nächsten übergreifenden Bereichsrunde oder sowas
Wenn man sowas hört ist das meistens schon mal ein gutes Zeichen für das der was taugt weil dann will der nicht erzählen so nach dem Motto
Ich bin der geilste und mein Team sind die geilsten weil ich der geilste bin sondern dann erzählt er so nach dem Motto
Ja wir haben jetzt die und die Themen bearbeitet und dann erwähnt er auch eure Namen ab und zu machen ist einfach daran interessiert das was das Team macht gut zu verkaufen
Und das ist schon mal echt ein Pluspunkt wenn man jemand hat der das macht weil letztendlich weil ganz im Ernst wenn ihr zu eurem Chef geht und sagt ihr wollt mehr Geld haben
Dann ist es sein Job das ordentlich zu verkaufen und das geht natürlich besonders gut wenn derjenige der mehr Geld haben will irgendwie im Vorfeld schon mal öfters gut positiv aufgefallen ist
Und das einfachste positive aufzufallen ist wenn euer Chef ab und zu mal euer Namen einwirft bei Sachen die gut laufen
Beziehungsweise da auch ab und zu mal Sachen vorstellt dann auch was da wieder cooles gemacht wurde
Man kann sich da bis zu einem gewissen Grad natürlich selbst darum kümmern es gibt Leute die machen nichts anderes als den ganzen Tag den Karriere grind
Und gammeln auf irgendwelchen Meetings rum und erzählen und loben sich aber das ist auch irgendwie bescheuert
Weil dafür ist euer Chef unter anderem da oder sollte er da sein
Was ich manchmal ganz gerne mache ist ich lasse uns zu irgendwelchen übergreifenden Runden einladen wo wir dann mal irgendwas erzählen
Zum Beispiel wir haben demnächst jetzt Jubiläum Versionsnummer Jubiläum Version 100 von einer Sache kann ich jetzt nicht so im Detail erzählen
Und da werden wir im November auch ein bisschen was größeres zu erzählen einfach dass das mal alle mitkriegen
Also es ist so doof sich anhört wenn ihr die Chance habt 80% gute Arbeit zu machen und 20% das der Welt mitzuteilen ist das besser als 100% gute Arbeit zu machen
Also von der Zeit her ja wenn ihr 80% gute Arbeit macht und 20% da noch Nutzt darüber zu erzählen
Ist besser als quasi alles geil zu machen und nie erfährt jemand was von euch
Es gibt aber so Leute und deswegen ist es halt wichtig dass man eine Führungskraft hat die das auch mit übernimmt
Am besten ist natürlich wenn man das zusammen macht und dann ab und zu selbst auch noch mal ein bisschen was zum besten gibt
Wie groß ist dein Team? Ich glaube 14 Leute
Keiner will Lehrer sein
Also mein BWL Lehrer in der Berufsschule der hat World of Warcraft Forum gelesen damals
Während wir was gemacht haben
Kennst du den und wenn ja was Moment kann ich chat kann ich das anklicken ohne dass da jetzt sonst was kommt
Ich habe keine Ahnung wer das ist kenne ich nicht
Aber das sieht mir auf den ersten Blick vielleicht tue ich ihm jetzt auch unrecht nach
Konsultant im Anzug der gut erzählen kann aus
Aber ich kenne ihn nicht keine Ahnung also ich weiß nicht
Also es ist jetzt nichts was ich mir regelmäßig angucken würde wahrscheinlich
Sieht nach Scam aus echt warum ich habe sie jetzt nicht so genau angeguckt
Du musst dich verkaufen können da hat er recht
Zweites vorstellen Job Angebot
Na ja wieso warum sollte das Scam sein
Das sieht doch
Also von den Themen her sieht das doch okay aus
Schneeball
Ich kann da weder Scam noch ein Schneeball System erkennen
Erzählt über irgendwelche Bewerbungsverfahren und Vorstellungsgespräche und sonst was
Was hat das jetzt mit Schneeball System und mit
Sonst wie zu tun
Ach vom Style her einfach keine Ahnung kann ich nichts zu sagen
Mich hatte das Bild im Anzug schon abgeschreckt weil ich habe halt genug so Typen äh ähnliche Typen vom
Von der Optik her schon gesehen und das war halt meistens immer ganz viel ganz viel heiße Luft
Zu ihm persönlich kann ich nichts sagen ich kenne die Videos nicht und es kann auch sein
Dass der erste Eindruck täuscht und der Content tatsächlich was taugt
Ich weiß es nicht
Ok das ZDF sagt
Das Quiet quitting ist wenn du zu wenig Überstunden machst und nur das Mindeste erfüllst
Wie zu wenig Überstunden
Es gibt nicht zu wenig Überstunden
Was soll
Was zum Teufel soll zu wenig Überstunden sein
Also diese Wort Kombination ergibt da schon keinen Sinn
Der Normalfall sollte eigentlich sein dass du keine Überstunden machen musst
Dann hast du innerlich aufgegeben
Naja also man es ist die Frage wie man das
Wie man das das klingt jetzt sehr negativ formuliert vom ZDF wenn die das so geschrieben haben
Man muss aber mal
Es nüchterner betrachten du machst das was du unterschrieben hast
Und du machst das wofür du bezahlt wirst
Die eigentliche Frage die man sich stellen sollte ist
Warum sollte man dann eigentlich mehr machen als das was man unterschrieben hat
Und das wofür man bezahlt wird
Eine der Hauptgründe warum das so ist
Ist bei Leuten die halt den Karrieregrind machen wollen
Die halt Ambitionen haben sich da irgendwie hoch zu arbeiten
In welcher Form auch immer
Gut die können das ja machen
Aber das heißt ja noch lang nicht dass das
Für jeden der Normalzustand sein sollte
Doch doch damit ist definitiv welchen geholfen
Nämlich allen die keine Überstunden mehr machen und das machen wofür sie bezahlt werden
Alternativ wenn sie mehr machen sollen kann man ihnen ja auch mehr bezahlen beziehungsweise weitere Aufgabengebiete geben
Was dann neue Aufgabengebiete was natürlich auch
Perspektivisch dann mit mehr Gehalt einhergehen sollte logischerweise
Damit ist dann beiden geholfen ja
Aber damit ist selbstverständlich wenn jemand sagt ey
Leute ich mach das wofür ich bezahlt werde das ist doch nicht negativ das sollte eigentlich der Normalzustand sein
Ich weiß viel ist das im Kopf nicht so
Aber da bin ich tatsächlich muss ich eine Sache mal sagen
Ich habe mich ja letzten Streams öfters mal darüber beschwert dass ich immer noch echt erstaunt bin
Wie viel wenig Ahnung auch gerade die junge Generation von Technica die eigentlich damit aufgewachsen ist
Was ich mir früher komplett anders vorgestellt habe
Dass es nie so sein wird mehr wie quasi bei mir und davor
Aber ja eigentlich ist es noch genauso
Aber da ist glaube ich die jüngere Generation einigen wirklich voraus
Viele der Leute die heute anfangen zu arbeiten beziehungsweise angefangen haben zu arbeiten
Gehen damit diesem Mindset auch ran
Die wollen nicht für die Arbeit leben
Die wollen und durchaus ordentliche Arbeit machen das ist nicht das Ding
Aber die haben keinen Bock eine 40 Stunden Arbeitswoche zu machen
Die regelmäßig eine 50 Stunden Arbeitswoche ist
Und da noch zweieinhalb Stunden am Tag im Zug verbringen hin und zurück
Und im Endeffekt 6 Uhr morgens rausgehen und 20 Uhr abends heimkommen
Da haben die keinen Bock mehr drauf und das kann ich verstehen und das ist gut so
Quelle Instagram
Okay wir müssen uns mal kurz an und was sagt denn das ZDF dazu
Also es geht meiner Ansicht nach dabei nicht drum quasi wie sagt man so dienst nach vorschriften
Also es geht jetzt darum nicht schlechte Arbeit zu machen oder dass einem alles am Arsch vorbeigeht
Das ist finde ich gar nicht der Punkt
Was das für mich beschreibt ist eben dass man einfach nicht mehr macht als das wofür man bezahlt wird
Und das finde ich okay
Okay was sagt das ZDF
Hä
Hat es keinen
Was
Facebook und Instagram so ein Rotz mann
So ein Schund alter
Guckt euch diesen Rotz an mann
Was ein Scheiß warum soll ich mich dazu einlocken
Kann das das
Hä
Oder muss ich mal wieder updaten
Muss ich mal wieder updaten kann auch sein
Schlimm alter Instagram so ein Crap
Ja komm updaten halt mal
Ach jetzt funktioniert es
Pog easy download
Wo ist es denn Video bei ZDF heute ja okay
Okay
Was sagt denn das ZDF
Alles klar was sagt denn das ZDF dazu
Im Netz wird aktuell viel über Quiet quitting diskutiert mache Quiet quitting seit Tag eins
Also ich mache auch nicht mehr als das was ich muss
Wie gesagt das ist recht negativ dargestellt
Wenn er gesagt hat ich mache auch nicht mehr für das was ich bezahlt werde so okay
In der Wirtschafts-Disziplin gibt es einen Begriff der das Phänomen ganz gut beschreibt
Ja Moment das sind für mich zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe
Ja Moment, das sind für mich zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Das sind für mich zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Man könnte das vielleicht zu übersetzen, aber ich finde vom, vom,
vom Sinn her trifft es das nicht so ganz.
Innere Kündigung ist tatsächlich, wenn ich, also so würde ich das jetzt sehen,
ist tatsächlich so nach dem Motto, Alter, ähm,
ich mache wirklich nur das Mindeste
und das dann auch noch schlecht.
Aha.
Das, jetzt, das sind doch zwei, ah.
Das sind aber doch zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Ich mein,
keine Überstunden, kein Stress, das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen nichts zu tun, ja.
Also wenn du quasi wirklich nur das Minimalste machst,
so kurz, dass du immer kurz bevor, kurz vor dem rausgekickt werden bist
oder dass du quasi das, was du machst, quasi auch noch schlecht machst,
das ist ja was anderes, wie wenn du keine Überstunden machst
und dich nicht unnötig verrückt machst.
Dass da jemand mit geholfen, nein, also weder Organisation noch Mitarbeitenden,
innere Kündigung ist auf Seiten der Mitarbeiter assoziiert mit...
Ja gut, das ist wahr, aber das sind für mich zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
... reduziertem Wohlbefinden, mit psychosomatischen Beschwerden
und mit niedriger Arbeitszufriedenheit.
Ja.
Ja gut, da ist durchaus was dran, ja.
Also ich würde sagen, ja, für die meisten Leute, die arbeiten gehen,
ist das Gehalt ein wichtiger Faktor für die Motivation.
Ich meine, was denn sonst? Warum gehen die Leute dann arbeiten?
Fürs Geld zum größten Teil.
Das ist dann ein Resultat eines Entscheidungsprozesses,
wo ich dann sage, okay, ich bin sehr unzufrieden,
ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe mehr in die Organisation investiert,
als ich herausbekomme. Was mache ich jetzt?
Okay, meine äußeren Umstände zwingen mich so ein bisschen dazu,
in der Organisation zu bleiben, also reduziere ich halt
mein psychologisches Investment und ziehe mich innerlich zurück.
Okay, ähm, also...
Naja.
Also eine positive Emots... What the...
Alter, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Five-Hat Ratio.
Also eine positive emotionale Verbindung zur Organisation...
verspüre ich nicht, ich...
Ich verspüre aber eine positive emotionale Verbindung
zu meinen Kollegen und Leuten, die ich dort schon jahrelang kenne.
Nicht zu allen, aber zu Leuten, die ich mag und die ich schon lange kenne
und mit denen ich gerne zusammenarbeite.
Aber positive emotionale Verbindung, dass ich jetzt sagen würde,
Alter, ich stehe voll dahinter, was die Firma macht,
das ist die geilste Firma auf der Welt.
Nö, muss ich aber auch nicht, oder?
Nein.
Warum muss ich das geil finden, was unsere Firma macht?
Ein hohes Pflichtgefühl aufweisen.
Den Eindruck haben, dass sie berufliche Alternativen haben.
Okay.
Aha, wie gesagt...
Für mich sind es zwei Paar Schuhe.
Ob du innerlich gekündigt hast
und quasi nur noch, sagen wir mal so, nur noch Müll ablieferst,
was halt irgendwie gerade so durchgeht,
oder ob du einfach nicht über Gebühren viel machst
über das hinaus, was dir quasi vergütet wird.
Das sind noch zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Du kannst auch trotzdem ordentliche Arbeit machen,
allerdings bist du dann halt nicht dazu bereit,
mehr zu machen, als das, was dir quasi...
Man kann nicht unbedingt sagen, bezahlt wird,
mehr zu machen, als das, was mir dir eben zugesteht.
Das kann ja auch sein, es muss ja nicht rein Gehalt sein,
es kann ja auch sein, dass man sagt,
hey, machst du mal nachts Wartungsarbeiten,
drücken wir das nächste Mal ein Auge zu,
wenn du einen halben Tag früher Urlaube antragen willst,
was auch immer.
Aber dass die Leute nicht mehr machen wollen,
dass das, was sie zurückbekommen, auf Dauer,
ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass das, was sie machen,
zwangsläufig schlecht sein muss.
Man kann trotzdem ordentliche Arbeit abliefern
und man sogar Spaß an der Arbeit haben, ohne zu sagen,
jawoll, nächste Wartungsarbeiten nachts,
und nächster Software-Release nachts, mach ich auch,
und den danach mach ich auch, hier bin ich auch,
und dann fahre ich zum nächsten Außendienstseminar
und schiebe das an, hoho.
Warum?
Das machen vielleicht irgendwelche krassen Karrieregrinder,
die in ein, zwei Jahren vielleicht mal
irgendwie eine andere Position haben wollen.
Aber das kann doch nicht,
das sollte doch nicht der normale Zustand sein.
Na ja, gut.
Ich finde, das hat das ZDF hier ein bisschen durcheinandergeschmissen,
mehrere Sachen.
Ja, aber nicht mal so lang.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, 14 Leute.
Ist der Typ wieder am Start?
Der Fernseher stromgeneriert.
Also, den Fernseher, den stromgeneriert, das kenne ich nicht.
Ich kenne diese ganzen Videos in die Richtung free energy.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr das auch kennt.
Es gibt ja auf YouTube ein paar Leute, die einem erzählen wollen,
dass man an irgendwelchen, ja, bei irgendwelchen Systemen,
free energy abgreifen kann.
Das ist eigentlich alles Scam.
Beziehungsweise, wenn sie es nachmessen würden, bringt es, geht es nicht.
Also, ganz ehrlich, wenn Überstunden bei mir
mit dem Gehalt abgegolten werden,
dann würde ich eher gar keine Überstunden machen.
Weil, das heißt ja im Endeffekt,
ich arbeite mehr, als ich arbeiten müsste, ohne Projekte.
Und das ist das, was ich hier in diesem Video gemacht habe.
Und ich arbeite mehr, als ich arbeiten müsste.
Und bekomm noch nicht mal was für. Na dann ist ja...
Dann könntet ihr mal komplett abschminken.
Könnten sich komplett abschminken
Ich weiß nicht was da wieder abgeht
Kein Winners Terminal?
Doch tatsächlich
Aber warum?
Du hast schon recht, man kann es so oder so rum interpretieren. Letztendlich ist doch wichtig, dass jeder weiß wer wann gemeint ist, oder?
Was sagen die Amis denn ständig?
Sagen die das?
Hab ich doch nicht mitgekriegt
Aber gut, bei den Amis wird viel erzählt
Leider ist einiges was bei den Amis angesagt ist bei uns dann ein halbes Jahr später auch am Start
Zum Beispiel eine Sache, die man ja bei den Amis schon länger beobachten kann, sind diese endlosen Gender-Diskussionen
Ich meine jetzt nicht sprachlich, sondern nach dem Motto Frauengehalt und Männer benachteilen und Frauen benachteile ich dann wieder hier Männer und so
Dieses ganze ewig rumdiskutieren um dieses Thema, das konnte man schon 2-3 Jahre vorher in den USA beobachten
Und jetzt ist bei uns auch angesagt
Was Erfinder aus dem Bapfe? Was?
Oh Leute, ich bin heute extra nur angekommen, weil ich jetzt die letzten 2 Tage gestreamt habe
Ich habe gedacht wir müssen nochmal irgendwie hinkriegen
Aber so ein 3-4 Tage am Stück Streaming Streak
Auch wenn ich heute wirklich zu kaputt war irgendwas sinnvolles zu machen
Ich bin jetzt noch eine Viertelstunde da, also chat wenn es noch irgendwas spannendes gibt schießt los
Großartig Videos gucken können wir jetzt nicht mehr
Und irgendwas machen bin ich heute eh gehirnmäßig nicht mehr in der Lage zu
Boomer müde, ja korrekt, ups falsches Emote, wo habe ich denn mein Bett ge
Chat ihr müsst mir helfen, ich finde meine Emotes nicht mehr
Wo habe ich mein, da
Wir implementieren kurz einen Mikrokernel in Rust genau
Ich hatte ja mal eigentlich gedacht ich könnte da oben so eine Suche machen guck
Das Problem ist nur, ich zeige euch mal was das Problem ist
Die Suche ist kaputt und ich habe keinen Bock dieses Projekt nochmal anzufassen
Das ist, ich habe dieses Board und dieses Overlay Ding hier
Ich habe das vor 4 Jahren oder so programmiert
Und das ist noch mit Vue.js, wäre wahrscheinlich schon Vue 2 aber
Uralt ich habe keinen Bock dort irgendwas noch drin zu machen
Doch das ist so lange her
Das war eines der ersten Sachen die ich gemacht habe für den Stream
Komplett neu machen das ist schon ein bisschen das war schon ein bisschen was aufwändigeres
Kann er nichts Open Source
Ich kann das schon aber das ist so hässlich da schäme ich mich für das kann ich nicht hochladen
Stadia ist auch irgendwo am Start
Stadia benutze ich eigentlich nur in Kombination mit sowas hier oder
Ich finde mich hier nicht zurecht weil bei mir ist das anders eingeteilt auf dem zweiten Bildschirm oder sowas hier
Wenn ich das im Stream neu baue da brauche ich ewig für das ist wie gesagt das ist nicht so easy gewesen
Du brauchst mehrere Komponenten du brauchst die Sache die das rendert auf dem Desktop
Das kann ja sogar Keymappings Leute guck mal das kann Keymappings also egal ich kann sogar
Ich habe sogar Shortcuts für die E-Mouse die ich nie verwende
Ne mit UWP mache ich das auch nicht
Muss man da Sachen hochladen können ich kann ja hier die Dinger track und droppen und hochladen und sowas
Da ist ja auch Text to Speech dabei guckt mal ihr habt ja hier
Kannst du hier Text to Speech eingeben?
Kannst du dann hier auswählen?
Oder kannst du die Weeb Texts zu Speech machen?
Oh ich glaube es ist gecrashed
Perfekte Software Leute
Ganz toll
Also kannst du echt vergessen ich will da nicht mehr dran
Ich habe auch kein Rollbackverfahren dafür
Bin gebannt? Ne das ist ein bekannter Bug den habe ich öfters
Das ist wenn ich nicht die richtige Reihenfolge von Buttons an klicke für Texts zu Speech dann geht es kaputt
Guck wenn ich jetzt wenn ich ich glaube
Wenn ich hier KW und KW reinschreibe dann rüber switche und ein und aus mache dann ist wieder kaputt
Ne das geht schon das das das geht
Das habe ich öfter schon gehabt dass es kaputt geht
Muss man es vielleicht so machen?
Ne
Man braucht die richtige Reihenfolge
Ke KW
Muss man es vielleicht ausschalten?
Ach keine Ahnung
Was jetzt? Kein Plan mehr was ich da gebaut habe
In Rust? Dann wäre es Placingly Fast das geht nicht
Na gut Leute
Wollen wir heute mal zur Abwechslung wieder irgendjemand hosten?
Du folgst mal gucken ob irgendjemand da ist den ich hosten kann von den Leuten
Den ich folge die es auch brauchen weil irgendwelche 8000 oder 1000 plus Leute brauchen es wahrscheinlich nicht
Dash Bunny? Ne ich bin zu shy grills zu hosten auf Twitch
Das geht nicht
Da bin ich zu pepo shy für
Ich will aber jemand hosten dem ich folge und der das gebrauchen kann
Der Sprecher ist online
Frage geht zweimal unter
Wollte fragen wie du Rust von der Komplexität her einstufen würdest
Boah das ist eines der komplexesten Sprachen die ich kenne zu lernen
Selbst wenn du schon andere Sprachen gut kannst
Wow
Dann hausten wir ihn wieder.
Raid, was macht er denn heute?
Switch.
Alter Werbung ey, ich fasse es nicht.
Wahnsinn.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung was er so treibt, irgendwas 3D drucken oder so?
Egal.
Wir raiden.
Wir raiden hin und her.
Passt zumindest thematisch meistens.
Halbwegs hier zum streamen.
Okay Leute wir sehen uns.
Ich hau ab.
Nächster stream.
Mal gucken vielleicht bin ich morgen ein bisschen fitter.
Bis denn, machts gut.